i like my humor like i like my cough
dry this next performer is the dry
cevion blanc of comedic genius
introducing emily catalano
thanks for having me it's good to be
here
[Applause]
uh i'm just gonna get into it
um i think the
key to staying sane during this pandemic
is just to keep yourself occupied
like a lot of my friends have been
adopting dogs
and i think that's really cool but
i can't afford to adopt a dog right now
so
what i've done instead is i just stopped
shaving
now whenever i feel lonely i just pet my
legs
and take them for walks so
maybe try that
i live alone i don't have any kids
i am an aunt that's been fun i like
being an aunt
one thing i like to do is i like to
wrestle with my nephew
but his mom doesn't like it because she
feels like i should wait
until he's born
so i don't know
i don't think i'm ready for kids of my
own
like there's just things i'd want to do
first
you know like first i'd need to like
find a man
that i love that i want to have a kid
with
so i'd have to dump my boyfriend
which just seems like a lot of work
right now you know i'm not ready for
that
but no i like my boyfriend he's cool he
likes me a lot too
i'm definitely like his type
and i know his type because the girl
that he was seeing before me
was a model and
the girl before that was a ballerina
so you know obviously he's attracted to
women
who will need financial support when
their dreams don't work out
it's kind of working out
one time one time i dated this guy who i
thought
was really funny like he would just say
the funniest things
uh but it turns out that i had just not
seen
anchorman yet
it's a funny movie but i haven't seen a
lot of movies i was very sheltered
growing up
i remember this one time in junior high
i saw this kid and he was wearing a
shirt with a marijuana leaf on it
but i didn't know what that was i
thought it was poison oak
so i went up to him and i was like hey
cool shirt
i have a lot of that growing in my
backyard
and then i became very popular everybody
wanted to be my friend
and i sold a lot of poison oak that year
um that's my time thank you so much
that was bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
[Music]
more